yes well what do i what today
whatever you need a strain read well I
would love a books Oh
toothache powder mm-hmm plastic ah yes
and some of the stop being gay pills
no I'm socked up on those just dumb some
toilet tissues don't mind if I do
ah what do do where is my Tom I know I'm
a failure I couldn't do it do it myself
yes hi I'd like to purchase a condom -
cops good here you are you crazy crazy
horny uh we don't sell rubber skins here
certainly not to a woman of all people
well then how am I supposed to have sex
for pleasure well Travis the other gals
on the corner of unwed Road and horrible
Avadh I'm a whore because I want to have
sex don't you want to have sex of course
I want to have sex I love sex it feels
too good on my penis so unless you'd
like to go around back could get bent
over about a gold medal flour or get
arrested nice just you leave bent over I
don't even like that position I'm more
of a lay there and take it kind of gal I
want the money I want the fame I want
the whole world to know my name